السيد طيبه من مسؤوله في الحكومه
الافغانيه تحارب العنف ضد المراه وتحمي
النساء الى مهاجره هائمه على وجهها في
ادغال امريكا الجنوبيه تحقيق النشره صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز عن مئات المهاجرين الافغان
الذين يحاولون الوصول الى الولايات
المتحده بعد ان تركوا عرضه للقتل والتهديد
في افغانستان
وفق نيويورك تايمز طيبه وزوجها وطفلها
ومثلها
3600 افغاني ممن عملوا ناشطين حقوقيين او
مسؤولين حكوميين ابان الوجود الاميركي في
افغانستان باعوا بيوتهم واملاكهم وفروا من
تهديدات انتقاميه قطعوا
عشره دوله ناموا في الادغال مع الافاعي
والنمل الاحمر ليصلوا الى منطقه دارين بين
بنما وكولومبيا بهدف التسلل الى الولايات
المتحده او كندا برفقه الاف المهاجرين من
جنسيات اخرى
في الايام الاخيره ربما هناك تراجع طفيف
في عدد الاشخاص الذين يعبرون هذا المكان
لكن الاسباب التي تدفع هؤلاء الناس للتسلل
وحمل عائلتهم وكل حياتهم ومحاوله اعاده
بنائها في مكان اخر ما زالت موجوده ولم
تتغير ما زال هناك عنف واضطهاد واخرون
يبحثون عن حياه افضل وهذه الامور بحاجه
لمعالجه جذريه
وفق نيويورك تايمز تفتخر اداره بايدن التي
خرجت من كابول في اغسطس من عام 2021 بنقل
نحو 88 الف افغاني الى اماكن امنه لكنها
ابقت خلفها عشرات الالاف ممن عملوا مع
الحكومه والمنظمات الامريكيه خلال عشرين
عاما يتعرضون يوميا لخطر الانتقام او
القتل لمتابعه المزيد
نلتقي في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات